اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى النافذه الجديده
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه نستضيف فيها دائما اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك معنا قبل ان نتحدث للواء فايز نذهب الى
ابرز التطورات الميدانيه على الخريطه
التفاعليه مع سلام خضر شكرا عبد السلام اي
اليوم هناك تطورات لافته جدا على اكثر من
مستوى هناك تطورات عسكريه وايضا تطورات
مكنتنا من معرفه ما الذي كان يجري عند
اكثر من نقطه اشتباك في قطاع غزه بين قوات
الاحتلال وكتائب القسام وبقيه
فصائل
المقاومه سنبدا من شمال القطاع ل بسبب
وجود عده تطورات لافته في شمال القطاع
شمال قطاع غزه ما زلنا نتحدث عن منطقه
مدينه غزه بالتحديد والم المناطق الشرقيه
والشماليه لقطاع غزه اليوم اعلنت كتائب
القسام انها قامت بمجموعه من الاستهدافات
لقوات الاحتلال في منطقتي التفاح والدرج
او في حيي التفاح والدرج المجاورين هناك
اصابه لاليات وهناك كمائن لجنود
وايقاع خسائر في صفوف هؤلاء الجنود طبعا
هذه المنطقه كانت شهد
عده انسحابات اسرائيليه خلال الايام
الماضيه من اكثر من موقع من جباليا انسحبت
القوات الاسرائيليه وتراجعت وايضا من
التفاح ومن الدرج اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي
اليوم انه سحب الياته ولكنه قال انه انهى
المهمه في التفاح والدرج القتال الان يتم
عند منطقتي الشعف وجبل الريس ولكن هناك
صور اقمار صناعيه سنشاهدها بعد قليل
ونتحدث مع عنها بالتفصيل مع اللواء فايز
دويري ولكن ما تظهره هذه الصور هو اصابه
مجموعه او تمركز مجموعه من الدبابات
التابعه لقوات الاحتلال عند نقطه قرب
التفاح والدرج تمركز اكثر من 20 اليه
حاولت هذه الاليات الاقتحام كما يبدو ولكن
قبل ذلك كانت هناك معارك عنيفه كتائب
القسام اعلنت ان في ال 31 قبل يومين
بالتحديد من اليوم تمكنت من استهداف اكثر
من 20 اليه اسرائيليه ما بين مدرعه وما
بين دبابه في هذه المنطقه اليوم الصور
التي التي اخذت من الاقمار الصناعيه تظهر
هذا الاستهداف وتظهر احتراق على الاقل
واحده من الاليات في هذه المنطقه ليعلن
اليوم الجيش الاسرائيلي انه سحب
الياته المكان الذي يتمركز فيه في مكان ما
بعد شارع صلاح الدين هذا هو شارع صلاح
الدين شارع صلاح الدين هو الخط الرئيسي
الذي يصل شمال قطاع غزه بجنوب قطاع غزه
كانت الدبابات قد قطعته باتجاه حيي الدرج
والتفاح وتحت ضربات القسام وفصائل
المقاومه والضربه التي اصابت فيها القسام
الاليات الاسرائيليه تراجعت هذه الاليات
الى ما بعد ما قبل شارع صلاح الدين حيث
تدور الاشتباكات والاشتباكات العنيفه
القسام تحدث اليوم عن ان واحده من المعارك
التي خاضها في هذه النقطه مع قوات
الاحتلال استمرت لاكثر من ست ساعات
متواصله من الاشتباكات ادت الى مزيد من
التراجع بالنسبه لقوات الاحتلال هناك
تفاصيل كثيره ايضا في هذه المنطقه
الانسحابات كثيره من اكثر من منطقه وشارع
هذه ابرزها سننتقل الى جنوب قطاع غزه كونه
المكان الثاني لاشد الاشتباكات ضراوه في
هذه المعارك بحسب ما يقول طبعا الجيش
الاسرائيلي الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعلن او هناك تسريب من قبل الاعلام
الاسرائيلي ان واحده من الفرق الفرق
المظليين الفرقه ال8 المظليه تقاتل في
منطقه خان يونس بجنوب القطاع مع سبعه
الويه وهي تضم سبعه الويه حتى الان لم
تتمكن القوات الاسرائيليه من اختراق مدينه
خان يونس تحاصرها من اكثر من ناحيه ولكنها
لم تدخل الى المدينه بعد ما زالت
الاشتباكات تسير عند مناطق او شوارع
المحطه والشارع رقم خمسه وطبعا منطقه معا
ايضا الى الشرق قليلا من مدينه غزه وايضا
هناك اشتباكات كانت في بني سهيلا ولكن بني
سهيلا ايضا شهدت تطور لافته بني سهيلا
كانت واحده من المجموعات التي تصفها
اسرائيل بانها من نخبه المجموعات القتاليه
وحده يا هالوم المتخصصه بحسب قوات
الاحتلال بتفجير الانفاق كانت قد شنت واحد
الهجمات على منطقه بني سهيله نتيجه
الاشتباكات كما يبدو تمكنت كتائب القسام
ايضا من دفع القوات الاسرائيليه الى
التراجع ما الى التراجع عن هذا الخط
الذي كانت تتمركز فيه في بيس هيلا هذا
التراجع بطبيعه الحال يتزامن ايضا مع
معارك قاسيه في خان يونس الجيش الاسرائيلي
قال انه صحيح انه نفذ عدد من الانسحابات
ولكن هذا لا يعني ان المعركه بالجنوب هي
توقفت هذه هي
ابرز التطورات ولكن هناك شيء عاجل الان
كما يبدو هناك استهداف بصواريخ للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه على مناطق وبلدات اسرائيليه
الى عبد السلام نعم سلام شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه الايضاحات وننول الاخبار
العاجله على شاشه الجزيره اذا صفارات
الانذار تدوي في بلده ديروت ومحيطها على
غلاف غزه نبدا في التحليل العسكري مع
اللواء فايز الدويري فيما يتعلق بهذه
الصور المتلك حديث عن شده المقاومه في بعض
المناطق ونتحدث هنا عن حيي
التفاح والدرج التفاح تح تحديدا هناك صوره
سنتابعها الان معك وكان من تاثيرها انسحاب
لقوات جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيل تقريبا 20
اليه بعيدا عن مناطق الاشتباك السؤال هنا
عن مدى
تاثير وقوف المقاومه واستهدافها للاليات
العسكريه باستخدام الاسلحه الممكنه في كبح
جماح التوغل يعني هو في الواقع حدث تغير
جوهري منذ فتره ليس منذ 48 ساعه او لا منذ
بدايات الاسبوع الماضي منذ بدا الحديث عن
المنطقه العازله بدات قوات جيش الا
الاحتلال تنسحب ولكن بصوره مجزاه بدات من
المنطقه الشرقيه من الشيخ رضوان انسحبت من
الرمال من منطقه تل الهواء من الشيخ عجلين
اي من بيت حانون من بيت يعني كان هناك
انسحابات لكن كانت منطقه الاشتباكات
الرئيسيه تتركز في المنطقه الشرقيه في
الشجاعيه و والتفاح والدرج وهذه المناطق
خلال ال 48 ساعه الماضيه كان هناك كذلك
توجه من تم سحب
او خمسه
الويه هذه موضوعها مختلف تم قبل ذلك نقل
جزء كان هنا ثلاثه فرق ابقي على اربعه
الويه اي بمعنى
اخر سحب ثمانيه الويه بقيادات الفرق
المسؤوله عنها الاربعه الويه اللي دامت
الاشتباكات يبدو ص تعرضت لخسائر كبيره
وصدر لها امر بالتراجع هذا التراجع بدا
ليس اليوم وليس امس بل منذ اول امس واذا
عدنا للفيديوهات التي انتشرت نلاحظ نجاعه
المقاومه في اصابه الاهداف وتتالت
الفيديوهات وكانت ارقامها كبيره لماذا
عندما بدات اولا القوات فقدت القدره على
التقدم ام والوصول الى مدينه غزه القديمه
وبالتالي جرت التحولات في البعد العسكري
والسياسي هذه الصوره بطبيعه الحال هنا
حصلت عمليه الاستهداف للاليه الدبابه و
انسحبت بعدها 20 اليه بعيدا عن شارع صلاح
الان هذه تمثل جزئيه معينه انا اتحدث عن
اطار المعركه في التفاح بصوره عامه والدرج
بصوره عامه عندما بدات القوات منذ اول امس
بالتراجع الان عمليه يعني ميكانيكيات
العمل للتخلص من معركه فاشله وفك الاشتباك
وقطع التماس مع القوات الجانب الاخر هذه
لحظه حرجه للقاده وللقوات اذا ما استغلت
بصوره مثاليه من الطرف الاخر تكون الخسائر
مضاعفه وهذا ما جرى
الان في ظل عمليه الاشتباك تم تطوير
مقاربه القتال من قبل الفسائل
والان حافظت على المسافه الصفريه حافظت
على الانفاق لا بل اضافت عليها الكمائن
الثابته والمتحركه
واستدراج قوات جيش الاحتلال الى ما يطلق
عليها مناطق التقتيل ونجحت في ذلك وكانت
صاحبه اليد العليا هذا سرع في عمليه
الانسحاب والاخلاء لماذا لانه لم يعد
قادرا على المواجهه وغير قادر على تحمل
الخسائر الان تراجع الى منطقه ما قد تكون
مبدئيا داخل غلاف غزه وقد تنسحب الى ما
وراء غلاف غزه يعاد الان تاهيلها لتوظيفها
في مكان اخر هذا النموذج يتكرر في البريج
رغم انه من النقاط التي اعلن جيش الاحتلال
بانه يستهدفها منذ اسابيع لكن ما زالت هذه
المنطقه حصينه حتى الان هناك توغل لكن يصد
الان الوضع مختلف في هذه المنطقه نتحدث عن
تخلي من قبل جيش الاحتلال عن هذا هذه
المناطق واجبر على التخلي في البريج هناك
عمليه تراجع يتراجع في بعض الحالات الى
قرب السياج يعيد تاهيل قواته يعاود الهجوم
هناك الهجوم الان من ثلاثه اتجاهات من
الشرق والشمال والشمال الغربي حقق شيء من
الانجاز للفصل بين نصيرات والبريج على
طريق صلاح الدين ويضغط بكل قوه لكن لا
تزال لا يزال اداء المقاومه متماسك يخوضه
مع معركه دفاعيه شرسه للغايه يوقع اصابات
كبيره اجبر القوات الرئيسيه التي في
الجانب الشرقي الى التراجع فعلينا ان
ننتظر الساعات القادمه لنرى ما هو مصير
الاختراق المحدود في الجهه الشماليه
الغربيه والغربيه النموذج ايضا في بني
سهيله في ونتكلم عن خان
يونس الى متى يمكن ان تصمد هذه المناطق
امام الضربات المتواصله سبعه الويه تعمل
ال
السؤال دعني يعني اطرح السؤال بطريقه اخرى
الى متى يستمر جيش الاحتلال في عمليه
الهجوم اعتقد ان اطار الصمود اكثر زمنا
الاطار الزمني اكبر من القدره المقابله
على الاستمرار هو الان يقاتل باربع في
النسق الاول وهي المره الوحيده التي يقاتل
في هذه الحرب على الاقل بنسق النسق الاول
يقاتل باربعه الويه مدعمه بسته كتائب من
ضمنها الويه النخبه ويقاتل بلاوا اين في
النسق الثاني في منطقه خزاعه والخط الممتد
من خزاعه الان لا يحقق انجازات في الامس
في شمال بني سهيلا اجبر على التراجع واجبر
عن التخلي عن المكتسبات التي حققها خلال
الايام والاسابيع
الماضيه الان اليوم القتال انتقل الى
المنطقه الجنوبيه من بن من بني السيله
والى منطقه خزاعه اي بمعنى اخر الى الجنوب
الشرقي من منطقه بني سيلا ولا نزال نترقب
ما هي النتائج التي قد تفضي اليها هذه
المعارف وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي في
التصريحات اللافته الاخيره تحدث بان من
يعتقد بان المعركه قد تنتهي لن تنتهي
تعليقك انا انا اقول المعركه لم تنتهي
يعني لم ياتي بشيء جديد المعركه مستمره
يقاتل بثمانيه الويه لكن هل المعركه هل
الجيش الاحتلال قادر على حسم المعركه
اجابه تاتي من جحر الديك تاتي من القراره
تاتي من حي التفاح تاتي من الشجاعيه اختر
اي منطقه في قطاع غزه واسقطها على الحاله
الحاليه لا بل هنا الوضع اكثر سوءا نعم هو
مكلف لطرفي القتال لكن مجال القتال واداره
المعركه في هذه المنطقه تخدم المدافع شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه الايضاحات اللواء
فائز ادوير الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي